thanks for coming on guys well thanks
for having us you know it's been a while
coming and uh we certainly appreciate
the opportunity to tell our side of the
story yeah you guys story is super
fascinating um
for the people out there that don't know
could you please just give me like a
brief
background each of you onto as to like
where you came from and what your
background is
well i uh joined the florida department
transportation in
may of 1980 having just served about
five years in the
navy i was an underwater photographer
diver in the navy
and when i got out the florida state
employment service pointed me to a job
in tampa with bridge inspection and
i went over and interviewed and bob
hired me and
we went from there and yourself bob
uh unfortunately i didn't have any
choice in where i was born but i was
born up north in connecticut
a small town called clinton where i
taught myself to dive
about 16. joined the marine corps
did my time in vietnam got some military
training and diving
ended up working for the department of
transportation was hired in january 1974
after uh several years as a commercial
diver
after i left the marine corps
back then we were statewide there was
only
eight divers in 1974 that covered the
entire state
so we basically divided up into four
different sections and we traveled all
around statewide and did every bridge
that was longer than 20 feet and deeper
than two foot of water
for the about six or seven years and
then uh we were assigned to uh district
one which is on
west central coast of florida covered
about 14
counties fresh and salt water same
routine
provided inspections to ensure the
safety of the traveling public
for the department of transportation
strictly underwater that's what we were
we were professional commercial divers
so uh that was uh the beginning of that
and
i got my uh uh tutorship under a
fellow named vic griswold who was the
second
d.o.t diver hired in the state in 1969.
the first i ever hired was a fellow
named dick barthel
the bridge inspection program didn't
begin until 1969 so i got in kind of in
the basement
and uh mike did it as well yeah it was
uh
pretty interesting back then so it was a
lot of one-on-one training and
a lot of water time a lot of more time
is it right when you started
that there was two divers in the entire
state of florida
that whose job was specifically to
inspect
these bridges all around florida there
was there's hundreds of bridges in
florida right
absolutely there are thousands there's
about 12 there's currently
ballpark about 12 000 bridges in the
state of florida not
all are water bridges but 12 000 bridges
give or take
probably about three or four thousand
water bridges
december 17 1968
northbound across the anclote river
the bridge collapsed us-19
us-19 that's right up there in tarpon
springs in pinellas county
one person lost their life immediately
the media suspected sinkholes because we
did have sinkhole problems back in
florida back then
there was no dot bridge inspection
program
period in the state of florida above
water or underwater
there were very few in 1969
that tragedy brought forward
legislation that was passed in 1969
that mandated that all of the bridges in
florida
be inspected once every two years
according to national bridge inspection
standards out of washington a young
fella
named ed burkett who is
still pretty active at work at campo
kissinger over in tampa
was assigned that responsibility of
creating and developing and putting
together a bridge inspection
the first two divers hired were hired in
1969
and there were only two divers
two divers that covered the entire state
wow
when that bridge collapsed it was later
determined that it collapsed based on
the fact
that the piling were constructed out of
steel
they corroded to a point that led to
failure
they then understood through that
through that legislation that it needed
to be corrected to ensure the
safety of the traveling public and to
let them know that the bridges were
being
maintained and taken care of when they
were hired
the immediate task was to inspect all
steel bridges in the entire state just
the two of them
they did it for about four years
and they hired two other divers named
pete gaddy
jack d now there were four divers they
split the state basically up into four
sections north south
east and west okay and as a team they
all
swept around and did as many bridges as
they could starting with the steel
inventory inspecting
from scratch there was nothing there was
nobody even had an idea how many steel
bridges there were
from there they eventually completed
that tack and then they went around and
did all the timber bridges
because there are a lot of old bridges
that were created back in the day
out of creosote timber piling especially
down south
still are quick really quick and fast
with concrete roads on top of them they
over decked them
eventually back in the 30s and 40s
when they started building bridges out
of timber they just had planks
they eventually over topped them with
concrete
and and asphalt you know as the
applications came along there's some
fantastic pictures
of the old alligator alley and being
created in the uh the
30s and and whatnot that uh show that
very very
very well they found obviously that the
the majority of the problems were going
to go ahead and be for some of the older
bridges many of them have never been
inspected
so those those divers ended up
hiring four more divers which created
eight
that's when i came aboard in 1974. so
eight divers eight divers that's correct
and there was only two man teams that's
the way it was set up
everybody understood and understands now
of course that the best way and the
safest way
would be three-man teams sometimes if
you're out on the water two-man team
having one guy in the water is not
always good having two guys in the water
is not always good
best would have been three however in
1969
wait did you just say the best is to
have three divers in the water at once
no no
would be a a misspoke would be to have a
three-man
dive crew so guys you could have one
diver in the water or two divers in the
water and somebody qualified to
watch them in the water rather than just
have two divers
and have them both in the water with
nobody with nobody or
have one guy in the boat watching the
other guys bubbles
you know it doesn't work that way the
best way would have been
however in 1969 that's just the way it
was
in 1969 nobody had any idea that the
waters that they were getting into
as you can imagine they were full of
alligators they were full of
unknown hazards like pollution and
contamination some of the waters back in
the 60s and 70s
were considered industrial uh canals and
stuff uh
fen holloway and some of the bridges up
in the panhandle with the paper products
jacksonville some of the fertilizers and
pesticides and [ __ ]
but the chemical i don't want to get
anybody upset but it sounded like
the chemicals that they used to uh
create paper products
they had a lot of problems with the the
discharge so it had to have been worse
back then yeah with the discharge yeah
the water quality back in the 60s and
70s
it was kind of atrocious yeah i can
remember diving in the sky with the
first couple of times
it was miserable and then back in the
90s you know when i left it was
significantly better and we began to see
a significant change
but back in the day when we were doing
the inspections the eight-man team we
were based out of orlando
oviedo technically and we traveled all
around the state and did our inspections
we eventually were absorbed by the
districts but then again we were still
in west central florida so we had that
responsibility in the skyway
so i had by the time the skyway accident
had
occurred i had a good four or five years
of
first hand knowledge and experience
diving on that structure
before you guys meet he came for a job
interview
as uh he advertised he didn't tell him
you worked in the paper for a little bit
did you work the paper
i used to be a stringer for the old
clearwater newspaper
what's your stringer shooting uh
freelance shooting pictures
oh okay you know just picking up weekend
assignments things like that that's
awesome
yeah it was fun the application uh that
only had dark rooms
yeah ancient technology yeah mike
mike applied for the job as a diver
back in 1974 the minimum qualifications
for a d.o.t diver
dive inspector or five years full-time
commercial diving
with military training or military
diving experience
a minimum of five years it was not
a recreational activity it was not a
sport activity
it was not a fun it was commercial it
was work
so in other words we didn't get to
choose which waters we went into
whether it was cold whether it was warm
whether it was clear whether it was
dirty whether it was full of critters or
not full of critters
critters defined critters is a widely
defined term i feel like
you live in florida however i i can
honestly say and i think my can too i'm
eight foot critters with big teeth so
happy that we
no longer have to dive out there you got
now you got lionfish
oh yeah you've got the crocodile
population has exploded the alligators
are off the endangered species list
we should have been on the the uot
divers should have been on the
endangered species list back in the day
and said the alligator however has just
where it worked out
so you said you needed military diving
experience did you what did you do did
you actually dive in the military
yes what did you do in the what did you
do secret
secret can you just give me like my
military specialty
was in vietnam right
now
yes i was in vietnam 1967
and 1968. sorry we're out of that and i
returned in 1968. yes
i was in vietnam my combat experience
really
you were combat yes yes
and so did you do a lot of stuff like
obviously i don't
know much about that but did you do a
lot of underwater stuff
with my diving experience i had the
ability to
uh blow up anything that they wanted
blown up whether it was above water or
underwater
my military specialty was the 1372
which is a nuclear weapons technician
so i was a 19 year old marine
with a key to the nuclear weapons locker
holy [ __ ] that's pretty crazy secret we
can't tell anybody there
yes no that's intense 1372. that's
intense so you were more than qualified
to be
a d.o.t diver inspecting um these
bridges
i met the qualifications and like i said
we had one-on-one for five years that
was a minimum before you got your
certification
i